there's a wonderful model by David Rock
a neuroscientist called the scarf models
stands for status certainty autonomy
relatedness and fairness and there are
five things which matter hugely to
humans on an emotional level but which
economics doesn't understand and which
we can't really quantify and I always
joke that the Uber map also has a small
status Dimension which is that I like to
time my departure from the building onto
the sidewalk to coincide exactly with
the card drawing up because it makes me
feel like Kaiser Soze at the end of The
Usual Suspects it makes you feel like
Louis XIV walking out of a building and
having a car draw up feels really cool
standing in the rain going I wonder
which of these is my car or maybe none
of them right so there are other details
and I think there's a little bit of
affiliate when you just get out of the
car without having to do any
transactions thanks very much feels like
a chauffeur rather than a taxi foreign